right okay welcome everybody to
today's infrastructure meeting tuesday
the 2nd of november
we
have um
zoom attendee councillor sopa will be
joining us
and apologies
from
councillor kit councillor abbott and
councillor arnold claims someone moved
the apologies
second moved
council ladlow seconded council lewis
all those in favor aye aye
there is no public forum
and we do have a major late item to add
and that's concerning the parking bylaw
policy
okay so we need to receive that you do
as i mentioned there's a major late item
can i have someone move that move cancel
the crack second
right i'll put that elbows in favor
all right
right we have received that okay before
i commence with the the items listed on
the agenda i'm going to open up the
floor
um
regarding the three waters announcement
earlier last week uh and if council is
just an opportunity
for councillors to to make comments it's
not a discussion i think
um
there's been a bit in the media but i
thought some some councillors may want
to
say something if if they wish
we have anyone uh we'll start with the
council clark then council
yeah thank you chair um yeah
disappointing the announcement by the
minister um
but i guess she had no choice given the
level of unease from the councils
and
she acknowledges that uh
seven councils were in favor fully in
favor of the reform
team were opposed and the other 50 sort
of had
a range of unease i guess for better
words
it seems like our um
our opportunities now will form with the
uh
um the legislation is going to be put
through the end of the year which will
have uh two lots of select committee
processes
and again it um
takes away a little bit of localism i
guess that uh
i'd be surprised if anybody from this
end of the country is going to front up
in a select committee
and and give a 10-minute presentation so
it's a
bit unfortunate in some ways and for me
it's not the issue of the loss of uh
ownership of the asset it's more the
control of the assets and
and the services that flow from that
excuse the pump
so that's all i've got to say thank you
council ludlow thanks gene i guess it's
it's not surprising and i'd always
always personally commented that i
thought it was a situation where the
government would need to
uh mandate uh a requirement for
everybody to to opt in um and it became
quite apparent that that was gonna have
to be the option as councils
struggled to find
a uniform approach or
the ability to
let go of their obligations to their
electors versus the new zealand inc
uh proposal that that um that three
waters
um
seeks to to change it's still
up in the air over ownership
you know it said that we still own the
asset i'm not sure how that works
um i don't think we do and and i i think
it's probably a case of um i'd like to
see us not be the people issuing the um
the invoices to consumers as well just
so that people understand that when the
price of what they pay for water goes up
remarkably from you know what's part of
their rates charge now that they
understand where that lies
not that it becomes a a duty great big
increase as a part of of the rates bill
because it's not actually
um a rate for this this council it's for
uh a body that takes in the the majority
of te waipanami
thank you
anyone else council crack it um thank
you councillor pottinger um i find it
really concerning i think it's like i
think it's no
surprise to any of us that they have
mandated and that's certainly been some
of the discussion that we've had around
this table but i just remain extremely
concerned about the future and not only
around three waters but more around rma
reform as well and the future for local
government all of these major reforms as
well as free waters and because it seems
to me that we really are having the
local and the local autonomy
stripped out of local government what do
we have left if we no longer have local
and local government
and that to me is just frightening
thank you
your worship
yes thank you mr chair i
was
admit
admittedly um
upset to see
you holding the front page of the paper
i think the word despicable was used
whereas i found throughout this debate
both sides have been
rational at a local government level and
the debate has been
kept at an even level
and of course that was followed up
with the sunday papers saying
the biggest lake in the waikato was
called lake fanta
because of the orange pollutants that
have been going down the water courses
and
i think another term they use the locals
used was carrot soup
so
there's certainly drastic work needed
and
i think this is
help at least be a step forward
anyone
in regards to
their words but i i think it's about i
mean one-size-fits-all doesn't work and
we know that within communities
and sadly it's i think the
greatest impact will be those that
are struggling
okay
um right i'll just just get sorry hello
leslie you want to say something
thank you mr chair and apologies to the
site later
thankless i had a slight problem with
connecting um so i missed
was this an invitation from the chair to
make a comment about the three waters
issue absolutely there you go
thank you
i'll keep it very brief because people
have said various things but look but i
just want to say i think
the time for some brand standing on this
issue has has passed
we have a seat at the table and a voice
to be heard there are going to be
opportunities to do that
and i think that
we do have to bear in mind that there is
a nationwide problem
there is a
now
mandated proposed solution we still have
some influence on how that might shape
up and i think that we have to put aside
all
um
[Music]
grandstanding field feelings
whatever and actually
really productively make it input to
what is going to be the final shape of
the picture
right um
evelyn did you have your hand up
no i was trying to draw your attention
oh sorry yeah my peripheral vision thank
you
um
as chair i've just got a couple of
things to say and i guess the irony um
is with the local government act and
some pretty clever people wrote the act
and there's a section in it 130
that is obligations to maintain water
services and they put it in there
so that
rogue account a rogue council
couldn't play with the assets of the
public they're locked in there and it
states quite clearly that you can't even
borrow against your water assets in the
states in there
yet what is what are the new entities
going to do and it seems quite ironic
that they can do that and what that
means then if you can borrow against
your assets
you actually
make them liable
against
seizure because you know if they become
an asset like that so i'm not sure how
they're going to work so how that's
going to work the other thing is
with ownership now
to me the test of ownership is that if
someone takes something away from you
and tells you
that you still own that
to me
you should be able to get it back
whenever you want to because it's mine i
want it back unfortunately we will never
get our waters back
so how do we still own it
the other thing with ownership is that
these entities are going to borrow
billions and billions of dollars so if
we are a part owner of these entities
do we then own the debt
where does that come in
no one's told us that someone has to
and the other thing is mentioned by
councillor crackit was about the various
reforms
and one of the reforms coming up is
local government reform and we're not
sure
it's going to be interesting to see how
territorial authorities engage in that
knowing how the engagement and three
waters went
um so
we'll just wait on that one
but but there is there is
light at the end of the tunnel so and
and so i think it is september 2024
there's a central
government reform that's up for grabs
so
we can wait for that
so i'll move on now with the rest of the
agenda
uh it's going to be the receiving of the
minutes
of the meeting on the 5th of october can
i have someone move that
move to parnia second council at scott
put the emotion all those in favor
that this is carried
moves us on to the activity report who
would like to speak to that or do you
want to take it in parts uh take it in
parts please chair with uh steve giblin
to cover the leisure and rec section
first okay where are you steve
uh thank you mr chair and good afternoon
councillors um
look i'll take the reporters word there
are a couple of updates that are key to
note
around the
environment southland item on the
existing pump station
should we i've just checking to see if
we have received formal notification but
at this stage there will be a paper that
if we do that will come back to council
for
approval
and just to note too that the progress
on the hydro slides
the team have made good progress and
we're looking
for an opening date within the next week
and a half so we're hopeful that we'll
be able to get
a community back riding under level 2
operations so happy to take any
questions
uh any questions
steve
councillor
steve just a and around the sculptures
is there a plan on how you want
this to develop
that's exactly what the parks team will
be working on at the moment obviously
we're making good progress
on the relocation of the umbrella
and
um but certainly working in partnership
with uh the potential new trust and and
identifying future locations and that
would be something to be brought back to
council
uh around our reserve management plans
and how we're treating the
town belt uh
and other reserves can ask us the is the
trust an external trust yes it would be
thanks
you wish
thank you mr chair they
i i must admit when i unveiled that
umbrella i thought oh no an umbrella
with holes and what sort of sculpture is
that
but of course the artist was quite
clever and that
he put everyone's surname from the
um
telephone book to the
electoral roll
and
so everyone could trace their names and
give a sense of heritage
are the bricks going to be moved yes the
bricks are currently being cleaned at
the moment and reinstalled
and one of the benefits of the new
location is the sculpture
works in many ways and one of those is a
constellation map as well and the
reserve that we've chosen gives a far
greater
connection to the sky than its previous
location which had a building as a
backdrop
thank you
councillor cracker oh thank you
councillor pottinger um and the report
activity report it discusses the removal
of the lollipop coin operated
um
parking meters
which is
both you know a bit bittersweet because
of course we're one of the only places
in new zealand that still have them and
but you know as as time goes on we must
move with the times and implement new
technology as well which i think is a
fantastic aspect to that but my question
is what is going to happen to all of the
lollipops around the city
so i was going to as part of the
infrastructure section of the report
take advantage of the fact that we've
got russell pearson here just to give a
little bit of an update generally around
the parking solutions um upgrades um and
i guess also to cover if people got any
questions on lake street or queens drive
in particular so i'll hand over to
russell for parking solutions
thanks mr chairman
um the answer for the law for the single
head parking meters that we will remove
them and we will sell some of them
there are a number of people who seem to
have an interest either in their garage
or building fences there's quite a lot
of interest in them and the rest we will
send to and scrap as there's recoverable
materials from it so it's quite a big
effort to actually remove them all
reasonably quickly there's
740 odd of them so it's quite a chunk of
metal to take away
any further thing on the activity report
no
no
just a question for steve um anderson's
house just to confirm it starts this
month
the work on oh i can talk to that so
it's actually started this week okay so
they're setting up site now so just to
clarify um
that it's earthquake prone strengthening
and waterproofing it's there's nothing
beyond that it's another phase again
isn't it that's that's right so it's
that minor external maintenance and the
strengthening yep thank you
council ludlow so if we're moving into
the infrastructure
um part of the report i just i had a
question about queen's drive and how
long
um
it's expected the work is going to take
to do once you've assessed what it is
that needs to be done
thanks mr chairman queen's drive's been
causing us a little bit of uh yes
concern over a period of time
obviously the top surface needs to be
waterproof and what we're starting to
see is the top surface
stones starting to unravel which starts
to indicate that it's becoming less
waterproof the base isn't failing so
we're looking at
options which will predominantly be some
form of sealed surface over half of it
we're anticipating so we're just working
through whether we need to do localized
patches or the whole section
and obviously the cost to replace the
top surface is quite
quite large so we're looking for that
interim period to extend the life
and we hope to do that over the summer
period and it's quite a short operation
but it is something that will cause
slight disruption whilst we do that but
we've yet to confirm the product and the
timeline for that
thank you
right
okay there's no more on the activity
report
that uh was to be
received
sorry can i ask um
is there any feedback from the meeting
in order tara
last week
erin would you like to speak to them
cool thank you chair um so the meeting
obviously went ahead in either tower on
thursday evening last week
there there was good attendance um
and both both in terms of the project
team that were there as well as from the
public um
look i'll be completely honest there
were some not very happy people there um
but we we did our best to take them
through the rationale for why we had
come to the decision we had come to um
there was a little bit of consternation
around that people felt that it hadn't
been a proper consultation process and
we explained to them that they were
right in that in that we would have only
been in a position to consult if we'd
felt that there were two good options um
and that we didn't feel that there were
two good options um so it was an
information session around why we had
come to that one option um and people
seemed to understand that a little bit
better when they realized we weren't
trying to actually run it as a
consultation process
um i guess what i would say is that
obviously this is the first week that
the odata community have had to
i guess deal with the impact of that
change
um
generally the feedback is for the most
part
congestion hasn't been too bad at some
of those spots that we thought it may be
particularly the current bay road
intersection we have had some feedback
that um one of the congestion points
does seem to be around about that
quarter to nine um time in the morning
so we are just going to have the team
out just having a little bit of a look
at whether we need to make any changes
around that at this stage
thank you
thanks okay
uh right i think we
someone to move that we received the
report
thank you leslie seconded
tanya i'll put that motion all those in
favor all right all right
right that's um
brings us to the major late item
parking by law russell
thank you mr chair and
thank you for receiving the report
apologize for its lightness it's just um
due to a timing and believing that the
this report needed to come to
infrastructure and it's really just
looking for some minor changes to our
parking by-law
um
bylaw allows for
minor change by resolution of council
but i guess if we're actually having a
much more significant change we would
have a full public consultation these
changes are really items that i need to
have implemented
for the changes that are necessary for
the city centre work some of them are
quite minor
and generally they're not necessarily
significantly impacting in some cases
we're actually looking to actually
improve the opportunity for extra
parking in don street so
happy to receive some questions okay
questions
no questions on parking
amazing still worried okay
right we've got the recommendations
there
that we received this report that the
committee accepts that there were
proposed amendments to parking as
outlined within the report and appendix
are appropriate and required due to the
construction of the city's center
streetscape works
and that the committee recommends to
council to resolve to adopt parking
control by law 2020
is it 2020. yes sorry mr chairman that
is actually a correction i needed it's
not the bylaw is actually dated 2020 not
2021. yeah so there's an amendment we've
got that there
2020
yeah 2020 so i'm reading off my thing
including amendment number one appendix
one
eight three five nine three four eight
six noting that it will come into force
on first september 2021
right can i have someone move that
please
group council ludlow seconded council
scout and put the motion all those in
favor
against that it's carried right that is
the end of the public session
um and now i would like to
move into
public excluded reasons um contract road
resurfacing to enable any local
authority holding the information to
carry on without prejudice or
disadvantaged negotiations including
you